oh hello everybody I am currently
speaking at an Orthodox Christian
Fellowship meeting for their leadership
and I have been a spare time and I have
been reading Steven Pinker's book
enlightenment now I also heard him speak
at on Jordan Peterson's podcast recently
and so I thought it would be a good
opportunity to talk a little bit about
his ideas about his book enlightenment
now and some of the problems that come
up in the manner in which he frames his
narrative let's call it
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world those of you who are
watching this will know who Steven
Pinker is he is a psychologist at
Harvard University social psychologist I
need studies on on on thinking on
society and he's recently been known for
pushing the notion of enlightenment and
how the values of the Enlightenment and
think of the Enlightenment are the key
to the problems that we're facing and
are the reason for all the positive
things in our world today his book
enlightenment now which is I think his
most recent book deals with the the
questions of how the world is getting
better the questions of the reason why
they seem to be doing better because of
enlightenment principles what he calls
enlightenment principles and also the
threat of this based on what he calls
counter Enlightenment principles and
also a regressive attitude going back to
religion and going back to all those
things so Steven Pinker he's quite anti
religious he really is a a kind of kind
of atheist materialist and Sam Harris
version of it and so it's very
fascinating to read his book and to try
to analyze the way that he frames
reality and understanding the way he
does that will also help us see the
inevitable inevitability of some of the
patterns that I've been telling you guys
about and some of the manners in which
we trained the world in order to present
to present a coherent story and so
Steven Pinker says that his whole way of
thinking his whole manner of presenting
the world is based on reason and that if
only human beings would Center their
activity center
their intentions on reasons then a lot
of the problems that are around us would
go away and this is what he calls
enlightenment thinking now what you
realize as you're reading his book is
that what he's also presenting kind of
underneath his his call to reason is a
narrative he is giving us the usual
progressive narrative so when we analyze
the progressive narrative we can get
some understanding about some of the
problems that happened when we went when
he frames his way of presenting the
world as being obvious and inevitable so
one of the first interesting things he
does is that he gives us these
enlightenment principles reason
democracy science and then he tells us
about the counter enlightenment
principles and then he mentions
totalitarianism he also mentions
Romanticism
you know this kind of focus on will and
emotion and all of that and that stuff
is bad like we need to get rid of that
stuff and we need to focus on the
Enlightenment principles which are
democracy reason and science and it
what's fascinating is the manner in
which he framed that because the countr
enlightenment what he calls the counter
enlightenment and the Enlightenment are
two faces of the same thing for example
in his book he quotes Hobbes quite a bit
and he quotes hard that is an example of
enlightenment thinker
well Hobbes was a he took his
totalitarian thinker he believed in
absolute he believed in absolutism in an
absolute monarchy and so absolute
monarchy the the the French monarchies
the English monarchies that the louis
xiv you know charles the first and those
types of apps monarch that tried to be
absolute
those were Enlightenment thinkers they
were done in an Enlightenment man
if you asked Napoleon what he was doing
he would have told you I am furthering
the enlightenment and so already you see
a problem in the manner in which he's
presenting reality he is able what he's
able to do and it's it's quite tricky is
he's able to look at the modern world
and to everything that he likes about
the modern world he's able to say
enlightenment and everything he dislikes
about the modern world he's able to say
counter enlightenment and by saying
counter enlightenment he's able to
suggest that somehow this counter
enlightenment is going back to the Past
going back to the the horrible things of
the past which are you know akin to
religion and do all that superstitious
stuff and so it's very fascinating
because the the totalitarian spirit is a
modern I mean obviously there are traces
of all these things in the past but the
focus on this kind of totalitarian idea
is something which happened at the same
time as the other Enlightenment ideas
that were coming back in the 17th
century and the 18th century it is it is
extremely there's something a little bit
dishonest about simply choosing the
things you like about the modern world
and putting them on your side and taking
all the things you don't like about the
modern world and putting them in a being
akin to all those horrible dark medieval
things that you want to get rid of now
we see the same thing in in the book
explaining post-modernism by Stephen
Hicks where he puts post-modernism all
the way back into the early modern era
and all the Philosopher's that he
doesn't like in the in the early modern
era he puts them he traces a line where
he says that all these thinkers are the
ones that led to to post-modernism and
he even mentions conte he makes his
Hegel and it's like it's crazy because I
mean the idea that Conte is not that an
Enlightenment thinker is absolutely
insane it's not insane but it there's
something extremely dishonest about
simply splicing the world like that
putting the good guys on one side the
bad guys
the other and and then telling your
story that way and but but it's a story
you know that the way that Steven Pinker
tells the story is is no is no better or
no worse than any superhero story where
there's a clear bad guy a clear good guy
we're on the good side and we're going
to defeat the bad guys and it's
fascinating because he obviously he he
presents his whole thinking as moving
away from that type of approach he
presents his whole thinking as moving
away from this identitarian ism that he
sees as evil to this conviction that he
sees as evil but at the same time he
presents a very clear narrative the good
guys who want these things the bad guys
who want these things they're totally
separate you know and we need to to
vanquish those bad guys but like I said
a lot of the ideas that he opposes
originated in the same thinkers that he
also supports you know Voltaire when he
went to England he he was amazed by the
the strength of the royalty and how the
how royalty was there to impose
enlightenment principles on the world a
lot of the colonial efforts of the early
modern era were done in a desire to
bring enlightenment to the world and to
to shine the light of reason and of
science and all of that on all these
other cultures and so these are the
things that Steven Pinker puts to the
side he doesn't he either ignores them
or he doesn't connect the dots together
in order to in order to to show how all
of this is related together so one of
the people one of the problems with the
way that Steven Pinker is presenting
reality and presenting his narrative is
the problem that Jordan Peterson has
been trying to express something and in
different ways
which is the idea that true religious
narrative tries to encompass all of
human reality within the story and so it
tends to to focus or to bring into the
scope of the story the
the light and the dark sides and the
left and the right hand you could say
all of that tends to be part of these
stories now one of the things that that
Steven Pinker does is by the way that
he's able to frame he's able to ignore
certain aspect or marginalize certain
aspects of reality and pretend that if
we just don't focus on them if we just
focus on on reason and science and
humanism then we'll all be fine but
there's a problem with that there's a
problem the problem is that human beings
are not only reasonable there are other
aspects of the human person which exist
and you can you can't just ignore them
you you can't just ignore them because
they're always there and they will
always manifest themselves so you have
to take them into account look I can
explain it this way if you say something
like reason only reason focus on reason
focus on reason then which you can do it
then when something unreasonable
presents itself when something
unreasonable within yourself or within
the world starts to manifest you can say
they're there I'm telling a told you you
need to focus on reason because look at
the unreasonable thing and look at how
its manifesting itself focus on the
reason focus on reason but the problem
is that that thing that but a reasonable
thing it's there you have to deal with
it you can't just say no no you know
what it's like I just want you to focus
on reason so if there's something
unreasonable that happens it means that
that's not what I told you to focus on
but the problem is that the side effects
of what you want aren't necessarily what
you control you can't just say a good
example it's like you can't just say I
want society to be based on reason and I
want to side to be based on democracy
and then you think anything that isn't
based on reason and on democracy if it
doesn't happen that way then then it's
not what I want it's not what I told you
to do but the problem is that reason and
democracy don't necessarily totally die
together
because the the and in the book it's
fascinating because in the book Steven
Pinker is constant
be complaining about how people are not
capable of being reasonable how the
majority of people are incapable of
focusing on reason but then he says we
need to be reasonable and we need
democracy so how can you have those two
things together you can understand why
people like Hobbs who said we need to be
reasonable rather pointed to a kind of
absolutism which is to have someone with
absolute power that could impose reason
on the world because people left in
their own mechanisms don't tend to
choose reason how many people do you
know who actually vote for someone based
on reason I'm pretty sure that Justin
Trudeau was elected because he has a
pretty face
rather than people being reasonable and
thinking reasonably about the problems
in the world and it's fascinating to
watch in the book how I would say like
almost half the book is Steven Pinker
complaining about how people aren't
capable of being reasonable and at the
same time saying that's what we need and
we also need democracy so so it's like
you can't just say this is what the
world should be like and whatever side
effect comes about that you can just
ignore it and pretend like well that's
not what I said I didn't say you know I
said it's like if it's like if I told
you you need to be nice and you need to
be really enough you need to be nice to
people and you need to never hurt
anybody and you need to to do only good
things do only good things and then when
somebody does bad things it's like well
no that's not I didn't I told you do
good things do only good things if you
do only good things then there will be
no problem in the world I mean can you
argue with that can you argue with the
fact that if you only do if I tell you
to just do good things and then there'll
be no problems in the world so if
they're bad things happening the world
that's not what I said I said do good
things and that's what that's the way
that Steven Pinker approaches reality
the side effects of his thinking there's
a there's a very powerful image that was
an engraving by Goya most of you
probably will have seen it it's called
the sleep of Reason produces monsters
and I'm sure Steven Pinker if he saw it
he would consider it part of the counter
enlightenment but there's a very wise
very wise thought in that engraving it's
that you cannot be only reasonable as a
person just like you cannot just stay
awake it's like if I told you you know
you could accomplish you can you can
work 24 hours a day you can accomplish
so much you all you need to do is work
24 hours a day and then you'll
accomplish all of this and then if you
fall asleep no no I told you don't fall
asleep I told you stay awake if you stay
awake then you'll be fine but the
problem is that the human being has
cycles we have cycles of awake and sleep
just like we have cycle of reason and
unreason or reason and emotion or we
need reason and we also have other
aspects which is our desire to belong or
desire for identity and what Steven
Pinker does is he shows us all the
negative aspects of belonging and and
and and as if we don't need that but we
need that and there are negative aspects
to belonging but we have to deal with
them instead of just put them aside and
say no no no just focus on reason be
reasonable and everything will be okay
and so when it does it's ignoring of one
of the of some of the major aspects of
how humanity works which is these cycles
we have human attention is is not
constant human attention falls from
attention to distraction or you could
call it from focus to opening up to
question all of these these pattern of
focus and opening or the pattern of
attention and distraction
the pattern of being awake and being
asleep
that's just how we exist as human being
and you have to take that into account
you can't just ignore it and tell and
tell people that I told you to stay
awake I told you to be reasonable and if
you're not reasonable then you're just
not doing what I said and so if you only
did what I said that everything would be
fine
and so there there is an ignoring of how
the human person works and some of the
inevitable elements of human of the
human person and so and so one of the
things that Steven Pinker does is that
because he doesn't see these cycles he
doesn't see them so so he he
this he talks about this progress and
then she sees I mean I was he sees the
totalitarian Moke moments in the 20th
century and he says oh no but that was
the counter enlightenment that was that
all of this progress that the
Enlightenment but everything that led to
the totalitarian spirit that's the
counter enlightenment and so now in the
world war two there was this blip
you know we fell into the counter
Enlightenment thinking and now we're
back on track and we're just gonna keep
going up and up and up and up and if we
make the effort if we just make the
effort we'll keep going up you know if
we stay focus on reason and focus on
that but that's just not how reality
works
that's not how human beings work and the
world war two was only you know it was
was barely a generation ago and and you
think that that was just a blip and now
we're just it's just gonna be constant
sailing from there no they have we have
cycles you pull the blanket on one side
it's going to snap on the other if you
if you say just just just just reason
then chaos is waiting in the wings to
come back and devour the this
overemphasis on reason you cannot have
just one it is not possible to have just
one
it is it is ignoring the human person
ignoring an important aspect of what it
means to be human and so what and and
one of the problems is that one excess
leads necessarily into the other and so
for example what's fascinating in his
analysis is that he talks about how
democracy is in danger you know how you
know we're seeing is it is democracy
just going democracy is in danger now we
can see the United States we can see it
in Europe we can see it all of this and
he is bemoaning the fact that democracy
is in danger
but she doesn't understand that the very
mechanisms of democracy lead to its own
its own problematic reality and that the
the mechanisms of democracy can lead to
a breakdown of cohesion a breakdown of
understanding and incapacity to to agree
on things and that that stalemate will
will will create the desire
or for a totalitarian regime and it's
not this is I mean Plato saw this in the
Republic Plato described the mechanisms
of democracy as leading to tyranny and
Steven Pinker has a wild statement in
his book where he says that democracy
has never led to totalitarian regime but
rather that it's thugs who took over
took over governments and it wasn't you
know the democratic process but it's
like that's sorry that's not what
happened in Germany the Nazis were
elected people desired Hitler you know
you can say what you want people desired
that the Germans desired Hitler just
like just like people in some people in
Europe now are voting for harder right
governments that couldn't even be even
worth you could vote for even harder
even harder totalitarian governments you
know the the idea that the idea that
communism wasn't desired by the people
that that the people didn't that there
was a mass of people that participated
in the revolution is absurd you know the
the Plato talks about how the excess of
Liberty leads to the access of tyranny
those two things are related you know a
traditional understanding of the world
a traditional vision of the world
understands this pattern and wants to
create a smooth sailing in the pattern
that's what the you know that's what
things like the liturgical years for
that's what the the manner in which you
know I've talked about the structure of
the church as from the center leading
towards buffer buffer areas places where
chaos is allowed in a little bit like
the carnival or little moments in a year
where we let in some of the unreason in
order to evacuate it you could say so
that we can restart the cycle and move
to something unreasonable but if you
pretend like those things don't exist or
that we can just we can just focus on
one and not at some point get the other
you misunderstand what a human with what
human consciousness how it works
human consciousness functions through
this wave this wave and you what you
want is you don't want it to go into
extremes you want it to remain you know
small waves of a ten
and and dispersion you could call it in
the traditional mystical practice of the
Orthodox Church for example we have a
the Jesus Prayer where one is an
invocation you know you you invoke the
divine name say Lord Jesus Christ the
Son of God and then you say have mercy
on me a sinner and so you have this
attention then you have this dispersion
and it has to do with breathing you
breathe in and you breathe out you you
you you focus you concentrate and then
you disperse and that's the pattern of
everything you cannot have only
inhalation you cannot have only awake
and you cannot have only reason to think
so is to delude oneself so I hope that
this was helpful you can check out the
the talk that see me picture you can
find him online if you don't know much
about it and I wouldn't suggest to read
his book I mean you can read his book
but if you understand this if you
understand what I'm trying to explain
the the reading of the book will be very
frustrating to you but there's a lot of
data in there that could be interesting
you know we can't deny that that that
science has brought a lot of material
good to the world and and that our
societies are peaceful at the moment you
know this mean it's gonna be like that
forever
but uh but yeah so I hope you enjoyed
this discussion on Steven Pinker's book
and alright guys I will see you soon